Welcome back.
So where I left off, we said
that we had this, I guess you
could call it, equation or this
function, although I didn't
write it with the function
notation, where I said, the
distance is equal to 16 t
squared, and I graphed it, it's
like a parabola, right,
for positive time.
And then we said, well, the
velocity, if we know the
distance, the velocity is just
the change of the distance
with respect to time.
It's just, the velocity is
always changing, you can't
just take the slope, you
actually have to take
the derivative, right?
So we took the derivative with
respect to time of this
function, or this equation, and
we got 32t, and this
is the velocity.
And then we graphed it.
And then I asked a question.
I was like, well, we want to
figure out, if we were given
this, if we were given just
this, and I asked you, what is
the distance that this object
travels after time, you
know, after 10 seconds?
Let's, you know, let's say this
t0 is equal to 10 seconds.
I want to know how far is this
thing gone after 10 seconds.
And let's say you didn't know
that you could just take the
antiderivative, let's say we
didn't know this at all, and
let's say you didn't know that
you could just take the
antiderivative, because we just
showed that, you know, the
derivative of distance is
velocity, so the antiderivative
of velocity is distance.
So let's say you couldn't just
take the antiderivative.
What's a way that you could
start to try to approximate
how far you've traveled
after, say, 10 seconds?
Well [? as I said, ?]
you graph this, and you say,
let's assume over some
change in time, velocity is
roughly constant, right?
Let's say velocity
is right here.
So you could approximate how
far you travel over that small
change in time by multiplying
that change in time, let's say
that's like, you know, a
millionth of a second, times
the velocity at roughly that
time, or maybe even the average
velocity over that time, and
you'd get the distance you've
traveled over that very small
fraction of time, right?
But if you look at it visually,
that also happens to be the
area of this rectangle, right?
And what we said, is if you
want to know how far you travel
after 10 seconds, you just draw
a bunch of these rectangles,
and you sum up the area, right?
And you could imagine, and you
don't have to imagine, it's
actually true, the smaller the
bases of these rectangles, and
the more of these rectangles
you have, the more accurate
your approximation will be,
and you'll approach 2 things.
You'll approach the area under
this curve, right, almost the
exact area under this curve,
and you'd also get almost the
exact value of the distance
after, say, 10 seconds
in this case, right?
But 10 didn't have to
be an exact number.
It could have been a variable.
So this is something
pretty interesting.
All of a sudden, we see
that the antiderivative
is pretty darn similar to
the area under the curve.
And it actually turns out
that they're the same thing.
And this is where I'm
going to teach you the
indefinite integral.
So the indefinite integral, I
don't know how comfortable you
are with summation, I remember
the first time l learned
calculus, I wasn't that
comfortable with summation, but
it's really, all the indefinite
integral, is is you can kind of
view it as a sum, right?
So now, you'll maybe understand
a little bit more why this
symbol looks kind
of like a sigma.
That's actually how I view it.
And please look it up so
you can see properly
drawn integrals.
But in this case, the
indefinite integral is just
saying, well, I'm going to take
the sum from t equals 0, right,
so from t equals 0, to let's
say in this example, t equals
10, right, because I said 10.
From t equals 0 to t equals 10.
and I'm going to take the sum
of each of the heights, the
height at any given point,
which is the velocity.
And then, what's the
formula for the velocity?
It's 32t and then I'm at
times the base at each
of these rectangles, dt.
And so this is the
definite integral.
The definite integral is
literally, and they never do
this in math texts, and that's
what always kind of confused
me, is that you can kind of
view it like a sum, like this.
It's kind of the sum of each of
these rectangles, but it's the
limit, as-- if these were
discrete rectangles, you could
just do a sum, and you could
make the rectangle bases
smaller and smaller, and have
more and more rectangles,
and just do a regular sum.
And actually, that's how, if
you ever write a computer
program to approximate an
integral, or approximate the
area under a curve, that's
the way a computer program
would actually do it.
But the actual indefinite
integral says, well, this is a
sum, but it's the limit as the
bases of these rectangles get
smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller, and we have more
and more and more of
these rectangles.
So as these dt's approach 0,
the number of rectangles
actually approach infinity.
So I'm actually going to, I'll
do that more rigorously later,
but I think it's very important
to get this intuitive feel
of just what an integral is.
It isn't just this voodoo
that happens to be there.
But anyway, so going
back to the problem.
So the integral from-- this
is now a definite integral,
extending from t equals
0 to t equals 10.
This tells us 2 things.
This tells us the area of the
curve from t equals zero to t
equals 10, right, it tells us
this whole area, and it also
tells us how far the object
has gone after 10 seconds.
Right?
So it's very interesting.
The indefinite integral
tells us 2 things.
It tells us area, and it also
tells us the antiderivative.
Right?
We're already familiar with
it as an antiderivative.
So let me give you
another example.
Actually, maybe I'll stick
with this example, but
I'll clear it a bit.
Actually, maybe I should erase.
Erasing might be a good
option with this one,
since it's fairly messy.
I think you know all
this stuff now.
I just need space.
Maybe, OK, so we have that
indefinite integral.
And we could actually
figure it out, too.
I mean, well, after t
seconds, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So and the way you evaluate an
indefinite integral, and let me
show you that first, is that
you figure out the integral.
So let me just say, let
me continue with the
problem, actually.
As you can tell, I don't plan
much for these presentations.
So the way you figure out the
indefinite integral, is you
say, and sometimes they won't
write t equals 0 to t equals t.
They'll just say from
0 to 10 of 32t dt.
Right?
And the way you evaluate
this, is you figure out the
antiderivative, and you really
don't have to do the plus c
here, so the antiderivative, we
know, is 16t squared, right?
It's one half t
squared times 32.
So that's 16t squared.
And we evaluate this at ten,
and we evaluate it at 0, and
then we subtract
the difference.
So we evaluate this at 10,
so 16 times 100, right?
That's evaluated at 10,
and then we subtract
it, evaluate at 0.
So 16 times 0 is 0.
So after 10 seconds, we
would have gone 1600 feet.
And also, the area under
this curve is 1600.
So let's use this to do
a couple more examples.
And actually, I want to show
you why we do this subtraction.
Actually, I'm going to
do that right now.
Let me clear it.
Oh, that's ugly.
I'll now do it more
general, actually.
Let me draw this twice,
once for the distance, and
once for its derivative.
So let's say that the distance,
yeah, well, let's just say it
looks something like this.
Let's say you start at some
distance, and then it
goes off like that.
Right?
So let's say we call
this distance b.
Well, let's just call this,
you know, I don't know, 5.
Right?
We start at 5 feet, and then
we moved forward from there.
And this axis is of course
time, this axis, maybe I
shouldn't do 5, because
it looks so much like s.
That's 5, 5 feet.
And this is the s,
or distance, axis.
And actually, I just
looked at the clock.
I'm running out of time.
So let me continue this in
the next presentation.